if you look the American Psychological
Association still admits there is no
scientific consensus as to exactly why a
particular person becomes gay or lesbian
right there that's a big BL that's a
huge admission because in all their
policy statements and everything they
act as if it's genetically hardwired you
know I think there are any number of
ways in to homosexual orientation and
there are many ways out that's what I
think is the closest thing to the truth
foreign
[Music]
for our discussion today is Dr Jennifer
Morris Dr Morris is the founder of the
Ruth Institute and Interfaith
International Coalition to defend family
and build a civilization of love
she was a campaign spokesperson for
California's winning Proposition 8
campaign defining marriage as the union
of a man and a woman she has authored
and co-authored six books and spoken
around the globe on marriage family and
human sexuality welcome Dr Morse well
thanks for having me I'm glad to talk
about this very important topic of
so-called conversion therapy so today
um you know as I've done some research
on conversion therapy you know my life
has been such that I left the LGBT
community after living in it for 40
years and I believe the LGBT myth that
conversion therapy was this big horrible
nasty thing that would happen to people
um in
until about a year and a half ago and I
started doing some more research and the
light started coming on I just would
like to have your opinion about what
conversion therapy is
well conversion therapy is the is a
pejorative term that has been invented
by the people who want to say that once
you're gay you're always gay that people
are born gay and that you can never
change and this is one of the big myths
of the um of the sexual Revolution
really when you think about it
um they they really want to push this
line that people are born gay and can
never change that sexual orientation is
a immutable innate trait sort of like
race you know that's what they're trying
to say and
um so the idea of conversion therapy
suggests that a preacher is laying hands
on you and praying away the gay you know
this is the you know kind of negative
image that they put on it but in point
of fact a more correct more
more descriptive term would be change
allowing therapy or sexual orientation
change efforts
um to to suggest the fact that when
people go in into therapy they may have
all sorts of objectives that are
determined by them the client that the
client gets to decide what the
objectives are and if what they want to
do is to lessen their feelings of
same-sex attraction that should be okay
and it should be okay for them to be
able to talk to people who will vote who
will assist them do in doing that and so
by creating this label this negative
label of conversion therapy they've
thrown this sort of very negative
blanket over a whole range of things
which in point of fact most of the bills
that ban conversion therapy they never
actually completely define it or they
Define it so broadly now that it could
that it could
forbid or penalize conversations between
a a clergyman and a client or a penitent
you know somebody who wanted to really
talk about what they have done and and
and hopefully change you know so it's a
very broad term and it's intended to be
a negative term it's intended to be kind
of a full stopper right so so I did get
that out of the way first of all you
know that that we really shouldn't even
use the word you know we should be
talking about change allowing therapy or
sexual orientation change efforts to
broaden the discussion you know that
it's not you don't start from the
premise that is bad you know with the
mirror label that you put on it and
that's at the invitation of the client
actually that's going in seeking help
there are a lot of people today that are
saying that you know change is not
possible and I think we need to look at
it Through The Eyes of of what is the
goal when you enter into that therapy so
you have some studies of which we're
going to put below that people can um
link to and a lot of people will say
from the LGBT community today that
um that you know these therapies are so
damaging but what what the goal is for
many people is in coming to Christ and
developing a relationship with Jesus
Christ it doesn't necessarily mean that
when that person comes out of
homosexuality that they're turning into
heterosexuality although there are
counselors that will talk to somebody
about if that's your if that's your goal
and your design and your plan we we can
help you along those lines what are your
thoughts as it relates to leaving
homosexuality as to whether somebody is
obtaining heterosexuality or if they're
walking in in faith in agreement with
Christ that might actually just mean
that I'm I'm going to live a celibate
life now right you know look this is a
this is a big topic it includes a lot of
people and so for some people
um it's going to be that all of their
feelings of same-sex attraction are
going to go away and and and they'll be
able to become be married to a person of
the opposite sex and have a happy
satisfying life I know cases like that
of both men and women who have been
involved in opposite sex relationships
for a long time you know so I know that
that's possible so so that at one end
you've got people who successfully lead
the LGBT lifestyle and successfully live
with another person of the opposite sex
and they do that for a long time
um then you have people who who leave
the lifestyle and who are celibate then
you have people who who have lessening
of their same-sex attraction but not
completely they don't completely lose it
and they have you know they have
struggle with it you have people who've
been traumatized and part of their LGBT
experience involves some kind of trauma
either trauma when they were younger
which led them into the lifestyle or
trauma that they've experienced since
they've lived in the gay lifestyle a lot
of people don't actually enjoy it very
much and would like to be doing
something else you know so there's that
whole batch of people so when you ask
does it work you got to ask yourself
well what are you talking about what do
you mean and the studies that that look
at it look at the question of did it
lessen the sense of Attraction did it
lessen the behavior did it lessen the
feelings and that counts as kind of a
win and what I would like to say about
that is if you look at psychological
therapy generally and you ask well is
this this this uh
therapy for depression doesn't work and
the answer is well sometimes it does and
sometimes it doesn't right and sometimes
it works partially and sometimes it
works for a while and then something
happens in your life and it doesn't work
anymore you know so to speak and so if
your criteria is that you never
experience the symptom again you know
you go into therapy for a troubling
symptom
um and Criterion for success is you
never experience that symptom again ever
ever well that's a that's a threshold
that really almost no therapy could
possibly achieve that threshold but you
know when you really stop and think
about what what's being demanded of the
of the so-called reparative therapy or
the so-called conversion therapy you
know it's a very high bar that they're
asking so that that's another thing to
keep in mind as you're just just
conversing with people about this and
they say well it doesn't work you get
you get to ask and you should ask well
what do you mean by work you know what
does it mean to say that it succeeds or
or it doesn't succeed yeah I think that
you know there's there are two parts
when I go for counseling
um I'm getting information from the
therapist and from the professional but
I have a I have a part to play in that
too as to whether I make an application
to the things that they're suggesting to
me and there are some people that say
well you know the the feelings didn't go
away
from a perspective of of uh the Bible
and religion I'm called to continually
surrender my Temptations to God
throughout my whole life so if I believe
in the power of Jesus Christ as I draw
into a closer relationship with him I'm
more successful the more I develop an
intimate relationship with Jesus Christ
and I would say that's when it works but
for people who are listening more to
their feelings and maybe denying the
power of Jesus Christ you'd be more
inclined to fall back and live how you
used to live
well and and even if you do fall back
and live as you used to live you can you
can shake it off and say okay I I drop
the ball but I'm gonna I'm gonna repent
and I'm gonna go forward here and that
that I would say that's a very common
experience for people for example who
experience any kind of addictive process
right think about that you know think
about people who are addicted to
pornography or people who are sex
addicts or people who are alcoholics you
know that they don't get better all at
once yeah I mean sometimes they do you
know sometimes the Lord will change you
instantly right that does happen but we
have no right to expect that right when
we've created habits of thinking and
behaving and we got friends who are
encouraging us in a certain way and so
on uh we have no right to expect that
it's all going to go only instantly
right
um so so part of it is the supernatural
level which you're describing there the
walk with Christ but also at the natural
level you can see this that it's a
process right and it's not going to be a
perfect door without or without lumps
and that's why I think the attack up to
ban conversion therapy and the attempt
to say that it is harmful to people to
even try to change your sexual learning
ticket that's why that's so destructive
and it's very important that people
resist that message because the idea
that attempting to change your patterns
of thoughts and feelings and behavior
that that's intrinsically harmful that's
not fair to anybody in my opinion I
think what you're saying is very
balanced and fair you know it's it's
kind of a two-way street to basically
say it's only a one-way Street of sorry
we're just going to cut this off and we
can't even attempt this it is fair to
say some people have success some people
don't that's what we have statistically
proven over any type of change like you
said drugs or any addictions or yeah
it's only fair to say that the data
shows us that that there's there's good
and bad on both sides of these fins but
it sounds like the picture they're
painting is it's all bad and it should
not be done in any case or scenario or
anything whatsoever I mean to the point
that you can't even talk about it you
will be tried and convicted I mean
they're they're getting to that level
where they're just gonna hush it up yes
yes and and you know when you think
about it that the message that is being
presented by the gay Lobby here
um and and when I talk about
um anything related to homosexuality or
or gay related issues I'm always talking
within the wider context of the sexual
Revolution and the sexual revolution has
a set of it has a Playbook that they use
on one issue after another you know and
so they will tell you that um being
being homosexual being same-sex
attractive being gay being gay is a
feature of your person that's your
identity and no one can really change
being gay okay well they'll also tell
women that abortion is not harmful to
you removing the fetus is like removing
a tooth
um and and women never feel bad about
their abortion well well here's the
thing it only takes one woman who
regrets her abortion to disprove that
very very strong claim right it only
takes one person to leave the homosexual
lifestyle to disprove the very very
strong claim that no one can ever change
and so that's why they go around hushing
people up or discrediting that you know
trying to make it so well there's
something wrong with you you know maybe
you weren't really gay in the first
place or you were depressed in the first
place that's why you're depressed up
your abortion you know they try to
somehow
protect that core idea that they have
which is that gay is a part of your
identity is part of your DNA it's part
of your person and you can never change
it and attempting to change it is
harmful well news flash there is no gay
gene the twin studies prove also that
there is that there is no genetic
determinism to homosexual practice and
homosexual feelings right and so we we
already know that this is not scientific
at all and so the idea that you continue
with this this charade that it's not
possible for anybody to change their
patterns of thoughts and behaviors and
feelings that's really unfair to the
many people who have aspects of their
lifestyle that they want to address and
lessen and change right you're not doing
them any service by talking like that
um what do you think or can you paint a
picture of what actually goes on in
people's minds as a society
when they hear the term conversion
therapy yes I think people like Sam
Brinton have created an image of
conversion therapy meaning that some
backwood preacher is praying over you
and trying to get you to change your
your your sexual orientation you know
that
um and and Sam brinton's story turns out
to be not very accurate or not very true
right
um there's reason to doubt it let's put
it that way
um but but the idea that
um that you know going off to a camp
meeting or a Revival or something like
that
um is is what we're talking about when
we're talking about people going to a
licensed clinician for help with their
thoughts and feelings and and dealing
with past trauma and their addictive
processes and stuff like that
um that that those two things are
equivalent that's what they're trying to
that's the image they're trying to
create they're trying to create the
image rather than a licensed therapist
doing the kinds of things talk therapy
that licensed therapists do they're
trying to create an image of a a a not
very intelligent
Bible thumping guy
praying over you and probably torturing
you in some way to get you to be averse
to homosexual feelings that's the story
that people like Sam Brinton have been
have been telling and you know if if
anybody's doing that if anybody's
torturing people out in the woods of
course we want them to stop doing that
but it doesn't follow even if somebody
is doing that that has nothing to do
with what's going on in the in the
office of a licensed there a strike and
as far as I know and I will put this out
as a challenge there has never been a
complaint against a licensed therapist
about this type of there if you can find
one you show it to me I I think it's
almost like
um disciplinary actions towards your
children some people will probably take
that to the extreme beat their children
tie them up and everything but then that
would be like trying to make a law
saying you cannot discipline your
children just because of few people over
here went to the extreme of that and
that's kind of what it sounds like with
this is like if maybe one therapist at
one point in time used those methods
then all of a sudden that would be
blanketed that that every every
conversion therapy is going to use those
tactics which is not the case at all
well I I I I I'm still looking for the
therapist who has done those type of
things I'm still looking where is that I
mean I don't know where that's going on
you know it's it's a bit of a guy is
that is held over the community in fact
the LGBT narrative is painting this
picture so that that even Christians let
alone Society at large is believing the
lie that's being propagated by the LGBT
narrative you know if we look back to
the ideas of of shock therapy and
immersion into ice cold baths and this
needle pricking and those kinds of
things I understand I can we can track
it back and find that it happened in the
late 1800s or maybe early 1900s but I
haven't found a legitimate story of
anyone who has experienced those kinds
of things and yet it's used to scare
people about conversion therapy and
while people are scared now they've even
included prayer under that definition so
as you're probably well aware you know
conversion therapy is Criminal now in 31
countries around the world and it
includes praying for someone
right it is prohibited it it need not be
criminal it may be a civil offense and
it may be something where you are where
you'd lose your license where a
therapist would lose their license okay
so it doesn't have to be oh we're going
to drag you up put you in jail it could
simply be you're going to lose your
license if you do this and if something
comes into your office and says please
help me with my same-sex attraction the
therapist is going to look at that and
go is this really a person who wants
help or is this an activist who's
setting me up to uh so that he can make
an accusation against me and and and
cause me to lose my license so even if
you don't go to the extreme of arresting
people and putting them in jail you can
put a stop to the practice with this
kind of chilling effect and I think
that's what the activists are hoping for
that nobody even gets started uh down
down the path and and you know I think
it should be said that some people are
helped by some kinds of therapy right
and unless you can prove that they're
sticking needles under people's
fingernails or something the very idea
that you're just talking to somebody
should not be something that gets
regulated I mean this is this is
professional speech in the context of a
professional service you shouldn't be
regulating what goes on inside a
therapist's office you know I mean
that's that that would be the the more
General principle and the fact is we
already have laws against Consumer Fraud
we already have laws against torturing
people right so if people are really
being fraudulently uh told that you're
gonna all of your feelings are going to
change instantly so somebody's talking
like that and that's consumer abroad
where you could use those existing laws
to deal with that somebody's torturing
somebody you could use existing laws to
deal with that but of course that's not
enough for the LGBT activists right
that's not enough for the sexual
revolutionaries they don't want anybody
talking about it in any positive manner
whatsoever they want it discredited they
don't want it even as an option on the
table for people and that's and they've
been very successful and again I'm sorry
to say they've been very successful
um so with that fear hanging on above
people's heads
um that like a licensed therapist can
lose their license
could they also be penalized if they
decided to
um
to what's the word to no not disregard
if they decided to like decline a client
because they didn't want to be put in
that position is there oh I don't know
you know I don't know right in other
words they're being discriminatory by
not taking the person yeah yeah it's
possible I don't know you know these
laws are made at the state level
sometimes they're made at the city level
so there's going to be a certain amount
of variation and that sort of thing
so it's possible but I don't know the
answer to that to me it seems like we're
we're really messing with people's
constitutional right for the right to
choose you know I should have the right
today if I feel that something is not
quite right in my life to go in state to
a therapist about anything I want to
speak to him about and if I want to go
to a Christian therapist I should have
the right to pray with that therapist as
well and so with what's happening under
this narrative that's gaining momentum
across the globe in criminalization
where we're taking away people's right
to choose and we're also messing with
their religious freedom yes yes that's
all true and and it's all in the service
of kind of remaking Society in the image
of the sexual revolutionaries right
um and they've been doing this type of
stuff for a long time right I mean loss
of religious liberty has been taking
place with respect to abortion in the
end and contraception and any number
number of things right that that the the
Christian resistance to the sexual
Revolution that's the problem you know
whatever facet of the sexual Revolution
it might be uh it's it's the Christians
and and and a few very Orthodox Jews who
are going to be the ones to resist and
so that they got to stamp that out so I
want to hear a little bit about your
conversation with
um Susan Susan Constantine because I
thought that was really fascinating I
got a chance to see that video and and
to see how she was analyzing his
behavior and it just didn't speak you
know truth so can you speak a little bit
about that experience of talking with
Susan yes absolutely so it it's Susan
Constantine I can't even remember how I
met her I think I met her through a
couple of other
um people who have been gay and have
left the lifestyle and some of them
referred me to her I can't remember what
the whole chain of events was but Susan
Constantine is what is called a forensic
psychologist and she
um has scientific methods for
determining whether people are being
deceptive or not that she's often called
into high profile trials to analyze
people's choices of words people's body
language people's voice stress there's a
whole voice stress analysis that they do
and she has a team of people who are
expert in this area and so she's been in
any number of of high-profile trials
that you might have heard of and she's
been interviewed lots and lots of time
and she's brought in as an expert
witness in this type of thing and so she
and her team analyzed a few speeches
that Sam Brinton had made Publix
speeches that they found on the internet
you know it's not like they were you
know trying to trap him or something you
know this is stuff that's out there on
the internet and they analyzed it for
his choice of words
another person analyzed it for the body
language and then they also analyzed it
for voice stress analysis and they came
to the conclusion that through many many
aspects of his testimony in his speech
he was quote highly deceptive okay that
the indicators are present of being
highly deceptive particularly when he
was talking about the details of where
he went for conversion therapy now and
what was done to him
they they felt that he was really not
being very truthful and in fact there's
something I learned from him that I had
never heard before there is a there is a
kind of person who takes pleasure in
getting away with a lie right and
there's a there's a smirk there's a look
that is called the duperous Delight that
he's he's getting kind of a buzz out of
knowing that he's lying and getting away
with it and they point to that in
several places in this video so it's not
one thing it's not one piece of evidence
it's the whole body of evidence taken
together that suggests that he's being
highly deceptive and you add that to the
fact that he has never been able to tell
you the name of the therapist or the
name of the place where he went you know
any important details are missing this
is not a person that we should be
relying on for making important
decisions let's put it that way
even though he was in charge of getting
rid of nuclear waste in the in the
environment but
apparently that's not an important job
if it hadn't if it hadn't been for his
high profile advocacy against conversion
therapy I don't think there's any way he
would have gotten that job I mean I
don't think any serious person Dina
would deny that you know that was a that
was a political
um you know a kind of not a stunt I
don't want to say a stunt but it was a
it was a kind of um political tokenism
you know he's our guy we're going to
prove something by having this this
non-binary person in this important job
and he's so confident it's going to be
so great and we're going to help burst
all these barriers and so on and so
forth well you know that that's kind of
come crashing down around his head when
you found out that he's you know has a
tendency to steal people's luggage at
how normal people don't do that not even
once and he's now had multiple episodes
of doing that so it's kind of it doesn't
look good doesn't look good for him and
his narrative I like they brought up the
aspect of other addictions and therapies
and stuff can you think of any other
therapy that that is frowned upon like
you're like we don't want people we
don't want you changing alcoholics
they're born this way where are you who
are you to pray over them and and do
these things like it seems like this
when it comes to this topic this is the
only thing that's guarded in this way
like we don't want you even praying with
them when and from a secular mind Point
that's the most harmless thing you could
do with somebody you're not in any kind
of way forcing them hurting them you're
speaking positive words over them you
know you're just speaking words but
you're not even allowed to do that
that's right that's right and and as you
say you would think if you were a
secular person you would think that
these these were these this prayer Talk
would be have no effect whatsoever you
know hey because they don't believe
God's gonna do anything in response so
uh but but their their idea you know to
be fair what they think is that it's all
of the delusion right and and the idea
that you can change is a delusion the
idea that that God's going to help you
change that's a delusion you're feeding
people's delusions and that's their
story that would be their that would be
their lie but the fact is that um that
people do sometimes change and sometimes
they change with therapy and sometimes
they change without therapy and
sometimes they change through religious
conversion and sometimes not you know
but the fact is people change every day
and that is the thing that the gay
activists do not want anybody to know
they do not want people to realize that
change is possible and so you know your
whole network of people who are once gay
and who are now doing something else
whether it's celibacy or heterosexual
marriage or just or just living you know
but they're doing something else that
they don't want people to realize that
this is a possibility because it it
disrupts their narrative that
um that you're once gay you're always
gay
um and and there's quite a bit of data
now that shows that it can that some
changes can be hap can be effective and
long-lasting and and that particularly
what people are highly motivated right
like they're already married to toward
opposite sex partner and they love their
wife they love their children they want
to keep it together you know
um and that person that person deserves
some help and support as far as I'm
concerned you know and when we have the
um you know the kind of whole social
narrative saying that your true self is
to go be gay uh that narrative never
ever takes account of the of What's Left
Behind of the people left behind and
what it's like for for for the wife when
your husband decides that he's gonna go
live a gay lifestyle what it's like for
the children that their dad's now living
with a with a with a man you know like
they
they never ask the question what is it
like for other people and that you know
there are people who are same-sex
attracted who want to spare their
families that and who don't want to do
that
um and so this is it's it is quite
possible and it happens all the time it
happens regularly and the gay Lobby
doesn't want anybody to know about it
and the other thing is that it's now
been shown I think quite definitively
that the attempt to change sexual
orientation is not harmful okay there's
another narrative an even darker
narrative which says that people who
have gone through sexual orientation
change efforts
um are at risk for suicide or higher
risk for suicide well if you look
carefully at that data that was a study
that was done in 2020 uh by uh blasovich
and and a team of people
and they came to the conclusion oh
people who have people who have gone the
same who have gone to this kind of
counseling they're more likely to commit
suicide well my Ruth Institute colleague
here at the Ruth Institute sociologist
Father Paul Sullins re-analyzed that
data he went to the very data set that
they used and he said wait a second
this data you can tell whether they had
Suicidal Thoughts before their therapy
or after their therapy you can tell when
they had therapy in the over the course
of their lifetime right and what you
find is that the people who were already
in rougher shape people who are already
suicidal were likely to go for therapy
right and then what happened after
therapy well after therapy they were
less likely to be suicidal right but if
you just ask the question over the
course of your lifetime have you ever
gone for therapy and have you ever been
suicidal you will conclude that oh gosh
they're because of suicide you know
that's like saying a marriage counseling
causes divorce well it's because the
people who are having the hardest time
are the ones who go over marriage
counseling right they're already in
trouble and hopefully the marriage
counseling is successful and they end up
less likely to divorce afterwards
hopefully that's the case but in it but
you you wouldn't conclude
without asking the question before and
after you wouldn't conclude
automatically that they were that that
that the therapy was harmful right and
that and yet that is exactly what blase
all have done and that story has been
told around the globe literally around
the globe uh that um that more likely to
commit suicide if you've had this
therapy and and that's that's simply not
a correct inference for the data yeah I
think to be honest if if you really sit
down and you probably were to be able to
analyze how people were treated either
by the therapists or people that were
helping them achieve a change or
something they're they're generally
going to be nice and kind right who's
really doing the bowling here I mean is
it the people that are changing and then
you see the lgbtq community come out in
absolutely bully people that are trying
to change and so it's like are they the
ones that are contributing to somebody
you know feeling uh even more scared or
suicidal or whatever because they're
being absolutely like they'll outs those
people they'll stop talking to them
they'll publicly slam them no therapist
is doing that right right and I I think
that's a very important point for the
for people who were once gay to keep
making you know that when I if I say you
know I was once gay and I left the
lifestyle and now all of my friends
reject me I used to be the bell of the
ball and now nobody wants to talk to me
you see this with the transitioners also
the the young people who who decide they
were born in the wrong body and they
decide to come out as trans and so on
everybody loves them everybody bonds
over them and then they say wait a
minute this isn't working and they try
to walk it back all of their friends
turn on them you know just actively Turn
on there's not just that they lose their
friends they make enemies out of it by
the time it's over you know so you know
let's take that into can we factor that
into the equation but but it's very
important that those of you who have
left the lifestyle that you keep saying
that you know that you know that you
know we've turned into Public Enemy
Number One here because we're disproving
one of their favorite talking points by
saying well it can be done it can be
done not by everyone not all the time
not perfectly but it can be done and uh
and use being able to say that those of
you who can say that credibly are a
threat to this whole narrative and
that's why they're so mean about it so
we live in a um an age of information so
with the research that you mentioned
earlier
um there's there's it seems to be that
there's research on both sides so if I
were a young person who
um was
was wanting more information about
conversion therapy how do I know which
sources to trust and which research when
they had them on both sides what advice
would you have you know that that's a
really good question because if you're
not a statistician yourself what are you
going to do you know who are you going
to trust when they when they interpret
these studies for you so
um I I think that that means that the
statistics themselves are never going to
be the decisive Factor at least not for
most people the statistics themselves
will be will raise a doubt in your mind
you know that well since it's on both
sides you know maybe maybe there's maybe
there's more here that I need to explore
and that means that people like you have
a role to play in um in in talking with
people and and being a lived witness to
the fact that it's possible and to the
fact that um that that you can have a
friend group right and you can have a
social life and it can be okay
um to to to make the whole thing more
persuasive but but you know I've looked
at quite a bit of this data and there is
a lot of junk science I'll tell you what
there's a lot of junk science out there
we as a matter of fact of the rift
Institute we we recently put out report
called protecting your family from the
top five gay myths which people can
easily get at the ruthinstitute.org and
one of them have been one of the myths
is that trying to change sexual
orientation is harmful another another
myth is that people are born gay
um you know these things are simply are
simply not true but by now by now it
should be obvious that there's no gay
gene there's an okay Gene people it's
been that's been disproven debugged
multiple times on multiple levels the
geneticists have disproven it the twins
studies in your studies of identical
twins any any idea that there is some
kind of hard genetic determinism about
your sexual behavior sexual orientation
that's off the table as a scientific
proposition and that's that's got to be
said now because that day that work that
research is very very solid you know Dr
Morris it's it's very interesting as
I've researched the LGBT narrative and
the power that has come through LGBT
activism on social media that when you
go to look for positive outcomes which
there are from so-called conversion
therapy because there really is no true
definition but anyone who wants to call
it that or somebody who wants to leave
the LGBT world it's it's hidden it's
pressed down in the results that you go
to search for in Google because of the
power of the activists working within
the LGBT plus community and yet LGBT
activism has screamed hollered and
fought for freedom it's interesting to
me that the freedom only goes one way
you only have freedom to become LGBT but
you don't have freedom to lead the LGBT
culture
that's exactly right that's exactly
right and my colleague made this very
Point uh when this big genetic study
came out that showed there's no gay gene
you know and it basically said that that
persons who live a homosexual lifestyle
who self-identify as homosexual or
lesbian or gay
um those persons their genetic makeup is
is literally no different from anybody
else's so why are we making it so hard
for people to choose the non-lgbt
identification why are we making that so
hard what's the rationale for that and I
think that's exactly right the freedom
only goes one way because you see what
these guys are trying to do with that
what the whole lot of them are trying to
do and it's not just the the gay part of
the sexual Revolution they're trying to
create a world where sex is a is a
sterile activity and where there's no
social significance to it no moral
significance to it you can do whatever
you want nobody's going to get hurt as
long as you're not uptight as long as we
have no taboos everything's going to be
fine well the people who think like this
they started this a long time ago well
before all the gays stops right I mean
you know they they've been working on
straight people on this for a long time
right and and the the holosexual aspect
of it is is important to them to the
whole ideology
because homosexual sex is intrinsically
sterile right you never have to worry
about a baby showing up from homosexual
sex so yeah they can do anything they
want you know this and this becomes kind
of the icon of what human sexuality is
supposed to be right and so it it plays
an outsized role in the in the whole
maintenance of the ideology and the
whole promotion of the ideology far
outside of the of the value of its
numbers you know it's really interesting
you mentioned um in in my bio that I was
involved in the Proposition 8 campaign
in California defining marriage as the
union of a man and a woman which one in
California you know let's not forget
2008 it's not like the Middle Ages or
something that's not so long ago and
California voted yes for man woman
marriage and and
what's happened since one of the
interesting things has happened since is
that there have been so few gay
marriages right there have been so few
same-sex couples getting married in fact
if you look at the Gallipolis and you
look at the numbers of sexual minorities
who are married and what you'll find is
that the vast number of people who
Define themselves as
um as sexual minorities who are married
are bisexual and most of them are
married to opposite sex partners right
so the number of you know gay men
married to other men and lesbian women
married to other women the number of
them doing that has not changed
appreciably since you know like right
around 2015 and hasn't changed you know
hardly at all so there was never any big
demand for gay marriage from the from
the community the the fight was really
about something else marriage that
marriage war was a proxy war for
something else and I think it was a
proxy war for the idea of marriage
having nothing to do with children and
sex having nothing to do with children
you know that that we're creating this
kind of new whole sexual Universe which
is a fantasy but basically it's a
fantasy ideology and gay marriage was
important part of that and the gay
community is an important part of of
carrying that ideology and making it
plausible to people making it appealing
to people somehow you know that's what I
think has been that's what I think is
going on
that's deep I mean you just said that's
a show in itself right there
that was amazing I mean
well I wrote a whole book on this topic
actually I love it here I'll show up can
I show up is this okay officially we'll
put a link to where people can actually
get a hold of this book because I think
this is extremely important so we'll put
a link in the description below and uh
if you guys want to check out this book
this is a a fantastic I mean just if if
we got a bullet point out of this book
and it was that deep I'm sure this thing
is a nugget of Truth well thanks a lot I
appreciate that I didn't know this was
going to be a book tournament thank you
I appreciate that very much you know but
all you know I say the thing that we do
with the Ruth Institute that I think is
different and better than other people
do that we do better than anybody else
let's put it this way is that we show
how all the parts fit together
you know you got the abortion issue over
here and you got the gay ratio over here
you got the trans thing over here and
you got no fault divorce over there and
it's really one giant issue right and to
see how the all the pieces fit together
that's a very important and helpful
thing I think you know to realize that
you're not alone in the than the
struggles that you're having
um that you have certain important
things in common with with people who
have never been anywhere near the LGBT
community but there are certain things
in common that you're struggling with
um that we would be helpful and
strengthening for everybody to know and
and to try to work together all right Dr
Morris I really appreciate you taking
time out of your schedule I know you
have uh uh a speaking schedule that
you're getting ready for that's upcoming
and you took time out of your day so
we're very appreciative of you being
here where can people get a hold of more
material do you have a website do you
have something if they want to look in
more into things that you've created or
done where would we send people to go to
ruthinstitute.org it's all there but
also get our new ebook reviewing the top
five gay myths and that's completely
free thank you Dr Martin thank you all
right God bless you Haley thank you guys
so much for tuning in to today's
discussion I hope that you got a
blessing out of it that was amazing Dr
Morse dropped some serious truth bombs
and I hope and and want to encourage you
to look into this more that's why we do
these kind of shows is we really want to
um you know give you a perspective lay
it out on the table but we don't want
you to just take our word for it you
should do some investigation on your own
so
um you know this is this is a much
grander topic than we can handle in even
an hour well we'll make some more videos
on these things so so you want to give
this video a thumbs up and click the
little notification bells for when we
put out more videos like this you'll get
notified and uh you know what we want to
hear from you as well if you like this
if you didn't like it make a comment
below tell us what part you really were
impressed by or you know if you
disagreed with it we want to hear about
that too so thank you guys so much for
tuning in and of course thank you
patreon donors for helping us create
content like this if you like our
ministry and you'd like to see us create
more content please consider giving us a
donation you can give a donation at LLS
backslash no llstv dot TV
lls.tv slash give thank you Brittany
lls.tv backslash give and you can make a
donation through there or you can check
out our patreon page and uh but thank
you for tuning in we'll see you guys
next LED live
we'll catch you next round
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing to show someone
you care
to make the world
place
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in five minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your journey
[Music]
thank you